we're in quarantine and apparently they
weren't quarantine on Scrubs also and I
haven't watched an episode of scrubs in
quite some time let's watch it right now
I'll explain this in a bit before I
settled on the outfit from my first date
with Kylie I had to run it by the
experts so be honest but not too honest
okay because I'm feeling a little chunky
my man is wearing a red t-shirt
underneath a white dress shirt untucked
with a blazer on top he's that combining
three styles maybe four into one there's
a solid note for me whoa short sleeve
shirt under a blazer by oh happy
birthday Laverne thanks Carla good job
brother make you face cake ERD Wow
I think I could have a piece of that
face cake I don't know what it is with
hospitals we love bringing unhealthy
treats and snacks to our staff lounges I
don't get it like I know we probably
stress eat more than most professions
but the fact that we have the
unhealthiest stuff when we're supposed
to be examples of health we do it
sometimes in good camaraderie to
celebrate birthdays there's like a
birthday every other day which means
fili fluff you don't know what a filly
fluff cake is you're missing out and
you're probably healthy thanks for the
shirt Lonnie are you doing this because
I forgot to shave this morning the name
tag on his nips what's wrong with this
guy well let's see fatigue fever malaise
we've been to Hong Kong sir I don't know
it's going into medically accurate
direction and on top of it who's gonna
take up a patient's chart and just start
reading it with a random non-hospital
employee
although maybe she works the hospital I
don't know and gone are the days of the
charts sitting at the patient's bedside
because people walk around there and
health information is a protected asset
could be SARS severe acute respiratory
syndrome and now with Cova 19 we're
facing SARS co2 in the beginning
actually when the International taxonomy
of viruses the organization that names
all the viruses named it's ours Cove - I
was so confused
why they chose to go with that instead
of Cova 19 and then it hit me
kovat 19 was actually the name of the
disease caused by SARS cough - and SARS
co2 actually has a meaning of SARS
coronavirus - because it was the second
one after the initial SARS doctor
suspect SARS it's causing quarantine
lockdown but why did he suspect SARS I
mean the patient had what fatigue
malaise basically not feeling good and
like a fever or something that fits ten
thousand if not hundred thousand
different illnesses and fYI when we do
isolations or quarantine that's not how
we do them we don't have metal doors
dropping and alarms ringing like that
it's a lot more controlled it's a lot
smarter because different illnesses
require different types of precautions
initially with kovin 19 we were doing
just droplet in contact precaution but
then as we became worried about aerosol
ice particles some hospitals went to
airborne precautions that required a
negative pressure air room for patients
who were admitted with the illness
that's why it was very difficult on
hospitals to manage all these patients
it's a novel virus we were learning as
we went like imagine normally we're
treating patients with already existing
knowledge of an illness now we were
treating patients and learning at the
same time it's not a ideal scenario for
ideal outcomes what have you done know B
quarantine is anyone ha ha she said
quarantine 'yes that's funny
unfortunately my hospital policy we have
to stay locked down until the labs come
back and that's going to take several
hours
so let's hang in there and not forget
this is all dr. Dorian's fault we are
short-handed there are only four doctors
here I counted more than that I'm
talking legitimate doctors turtlehead
here pee pants is a pathologist so he
doesn't count Johnson is a dermatologist
which is Greek for fake doctor and fake
doctor I can only imagine how a
dermatologist or pathologist feels when
they're on an airplane and someone says
is there a doctor on board and they
volunteer there's no way they know what
to do unless they're fresh out of
residency and they just got some
training but otherwise like if you're
seeing skin conditions all the time or
you're looking at slides how do you know
how to handle
anaphylaxis in the air without a EpiPen
or an epi auto-injector by the way we're
gonna have a dermatologist on very soon
and not to critique my horrible SPF
situation here please don't judge me I
know it's embarrassing I didn't apply
the SPF correctly I don't know how I did
it so poorly but look at this board I'm
a surgeon and there's no surgery why do
you think I brought you in here oh my
god that rhythm on the monitor
I don't understand they have all of this
equipment they have medical aids but
what is going on on their monitors the
rhythms that are being shown looks like
the patient is literally coding as we
speak I don't understand just show a
proper rhythm the only thing I did test
more than treating patients or treating
patients on an empty stomach I'm
famished
I'm in there for eight minutes I haven't
eaten since yesterday I've been starving
myself because I was going to a steak
house tonight it was just gonna be me a
24-ounce porterhouse and a fistful of
blood thinners this is like the exact
opposite of the chief of Family Medicine
that I worked with well he's technically
the family medicine program director dr.
Joseph tribuna he will starve himself
for ten days if he has to in order to
make sure his patients are taken care of
I have never seen an attending who
during rounds will not only make sure
that they're getting the diagnosis right
the patient's taking care of all of that
but then also they'll he would literally
open a patient's food for them help them
eat it like no job was too big or too
small to make sure that the patient was
comfortable so how's it going Kylie
there was nothing exciting going on this
sucks I need to look like a stud and a
doctor can look like a stud unless he's
saving somebody's life I need someone
have a heart attack got 20 bucks come on
Steve stay with me buddy you're not
getting this one oh my god what are you
doing I mean I know it's fake but it's
too fake it's a fake within a fake it's
a show that's poorly medically acted on
top of a fake person having a fake heart
attack okay there's too many things
could you make your face a little bit of
everybody come on
I want our money what fifty bucks or I
tell the girl I don't have any other
doctor over here stat
you said I need another doctor stat
$30.00 20 untappd that's Johnson he
floated I need a dermatologist over here
my god these chest compressions are so
bad time to shine do you need is it a
rash look you want 50 bucks we only have
20 you know I feel like you guys just
use me for my money you have a trust
fund Oh give me the money alive
stop shocking people whose hearts are
beating normally please this happens too
often on these shows at least it's
comedic here and by the way with does
heart attack if someone has a heart
attack you don't just run and start
doing chest compressions if they're
breathing and have a pulse the chest
compressions are when for a heart stops
literally so the heart's not beating
you're doing chest compressions to
simulate a heart beat like even if you
do chest compressions perfectly you're
still only moving the blood circulating
the blood at about 20% of the efficiency
that the heart would do it normally so
know if someone has a heart attack you
don't just start doing chest
compressions and you certainly don't
just shock them out of nowhere the main
thing you want to do when someone's
having a heart attack is to open up
their arteries that are currently
blocked and there's multiple ways we do
it stents there's procedures medications
and a lot of the times it's very
time-sensitive actually there's a
something known as door to balloon time
which is like when you come in with your
the first signs of a heart attack we
know we have to get you in that cath lab
to open up your blocked artery otherwise
cardiac tissue is gonna die and some of
the damage could be permanent seeing you
your element today you seem so here it
comes
sexy genuine she what it says sexy of a
mustache you know James lied all the
time and I don't know it's just nice to
be with a guy contrast Trust is the
foundation of any good relationship
spousal or otherwise work or otherwise
friendship or otherwise doctor or
patient or otherwise I don't have
anymore LaVon I bet you're tempted to
break open that face kangkang just tear
it apart no one's touching this oh I
don't care I'm not even hungry why is it
called face cake why is it called
some would explain these hi hey
I'm Glenn I'm Glenn look let's not go
down that road again
why is his ID like floating on his chest
do you guys see that I don't understand
why call it and tell me about you guys
is it just me or in scrubs they always
have conversations over patients that
are comatose just go into a meeting room
there's so many empty rooms why do you
have to do it over a patient's body the
lab results are back and there is no
SARS the quarantine is over I just want
to know why they thought it was SARS in
the first place why do they have to
quarantine the entire department why
didn't they just do a flu swab and a
respiratory panel right away get some
quick results find out that it's RSV and
just go about their merry way
instead they order a complicated test
that takes all right it's the show I get
it check out this house m.d. episode
about a quarantine or these crazy
Facebook outposts are they even real
what as always stay happy and healthy
but which one you're clicking on
[Music]